The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good morning
everyone, let's get started.
So part two of our two lecture
sequence on network flow.
So all the pain
involved in the concepts
and notation from Tuesday turns
into algorithmic fun today.
But we will do a little
bit of a review just
to make sure we're
all on the same page
with respect to all
of these notions
that we talked about
on flow networks.
So we call that a
flow network is simply
a directed graph,
GVE, and each edge
is going to have two
numbers associated with it.
If you see something
like 1:3, this
means that this is the flow,
and that's the capacity.
We have a basic
constraint dissociated
with the flow not exceeding
the capacity on any given edge.
And we also have the
laws of conservation
that say that other than the
sink in the source, which
are the two distinguished
vertices in G V E,
you're going to have
a situation where
for any intermediate vertex, all
of the flow entering the vertex
has to leave the vertex.
And with those two
constraints you
need to find the max flow
in your flow network.
The flow value corresponding
to this potential max
flow, or some flow, is
F equaling f of s of V.
And so s is the source.
V corresponds to
all of the vertices.
And you're looking at pushing
flow from the source vertex
to any of the vertices, and
thus the V includes t, as well.
And that this is
essentially a flow value,
and we showed-- this is
implicit summation notation,
we showed, using a
little bit of algebra,
that this equals f of V t.
And that's going to hold because
of flow conservation primarily.
So that was not
particularly surprising.
Something that was a
little more surprising,
or is a little
more surprising, is
that you can have an arbitrary
cut in the flow network,
and a cut corresponds
to any partition.
S, T, such that s belongs to
S, the source belongs to S,
and the sink belongs to T,
and that's essentially a cut.
And so obviously there could
be exponentially many cuts
in a given flow network.
But the amazing
thing is that you
can show a lemma that
says that, regardless
of what the actual flow values
are in any of these edges--
across any cut you're
going to see this flow.
And this is true for any cut S,
T. The corollary to this lemma
is that the flow is
going to be less than
or equal to the
capacity of any cut.
And that simply comes
from the edge constraints.
You know that the flow
value corresponding
to any particular
edge has to be less
than the capacity of that edge.
So you obey that
constraint and you just
look at the edges that go from
S to T, sum up those capacities,
and your maximum flow or any
flow is bounded, [INAUDIBLE],
by that quantity.
And that's our c S T.
So you now have a relationship
between the minimum capacity
cut and the max flow.
We didn't actually
exploit that in the sense
of the algorithm itself, the
operation of the algorithm.
But we're going to
actually exploit
the notion of a cut when we
prove this algorithm that I got
to late on Tuesday's
lecture that corresponds
to the Ford-Fulkerson algorithm.
I showed you the
execution of it.
In order to prove
that it's correct
we're going to need
this notion of that
bound on the flow value
given any cut in the network.
So the max flow
related to min-cut.
But before we get to that.
Just to catch you
up on the algorithm
that we actually got to, the
Ford-Fulkerson algorithm, that
was based on the notion
of a residual graph.
This is now a new graph,
G f, which is V, E f,
so it depends on the flow.
You computed based on G,
based on the given flow f.
And this graph has edges that
have strictly positive residual
capacities which are
defined as the C f u,
v equals C u,v minus f u, v.
And this needs to be strictly
greater than 0 in order for
the edge to exist in G of f.
So if this is zero then you
don't have an edge between u
and v in G of f.
If it's one or greater assuming
integral flow values, you will.
And in the residual graph--
two more quick definitions.
One of which you saw
last time, and another
that I just verbalized, is the
notion of an augmenting path.
And this is any path
from s to t in G f.
So if there's a path
from S to T in G f
you do not have a maximum flow.
There is an augmenting path.
You're going to be able to
increase the flow corresponding
to the f value, that gave
you your residual network, G
S of f.
And how much can you
increase this flow by?
How much can you increase f by?
That is termed the
residual capacity.
And the residual capacity
of an augmenting path
is simply C f of P,
that's what we're
going to call it,
C f of P, equals
the minimum value of
the residual capacities
along the path.
So this would be C f u,v,
and that's pretty much it.
And some examples should
make this clearer.
If we look at what the
actual algorithm is, and go
through a simpler example
than we did last time,
but it'll give you a
sense of how augmentations
are going to change the flow.
How augmenting paths appear
and eventually disappear
as the flow increases and
reaches the maximum flow.
So this simply
corresponds to, as I
said, walking through
the augmenting path,
looking at each of the
residual capacities,
and picking the Min value.
So the Ford-Fulkerson
algorithm, which
is the first algorithm for
max flow continues to be used,
sets the flow on each
of the edges to be zero.
So you just set
everything to zero.
Clearly satisfies
flow conservation,
satisfies all the
edge capacities.
And you have literally
three lines of code
here, while an augmenting
path in G f exists.
So there's a lot going on here,
you have to compute G of f,
I mean it's three lines
of code, but the sub
routines calls, which
are fairly complicated,
you have to compute
g of f, given f,
and initially it's all zeros.
And then eventually
it's going to change,
or immediately after you
discover an augmenting path.
And now you have discovered
an augmenting path.
So you have to now do
either breadth-first search
or depth-first search, in
order to discover whether this
is a path from s
to t because that's
the definition of
an augmenting path.
And then the last line of code
says, augment f by C f of p.
And again this is
fairly involved.
You have to take
the path in G of f.
You're going to increase
the values of the edges that
correspond to G of f translating
those edges back to G.
And there's possibly an
inversion in direction
that is associated
with that translation.
And so if you take a really
straightforward example.
Let's say if you have G is s,
and this one vertex here, a,
and then you have t.
And right now I
have 1:2 and 1:4.
I now am going to
compute G of f.
So G of f is going to be-- I'm
just going to write down s,
a, and t because the
vertices are all the same.
The edges are
obviously different.
Am I going to have
an edge from s to a?
Yes.
And what number should
I put on that edge?
1, and that's because
it's 2 minus 1,
not because it's just plain 1.
And this edge here is going to
have a residual capacity of 1,
and that just comes
directly from that 1.
And what that means is,
and this is important,
what that means is that, in
effect, this residual capacity
says in this direction you
still have a capacity of 1.
Which means that
in this direction
you could reduce by one.
OK, that's the important
thing to remember.
And over here I'm
going to have--
this way I'm going to
have 3 and coming back
I'm going to have 1.
All right, so
straightforward example but I
think evocative in the sense
that it applies the concepts
that we've seen so
far other than cuts.
And we'll get to that.
And what happens here, is
there a path from s to t?
Absolutely.
And what is the
residual capacity
of the path from s to t?
It's one because you've got a
1 here, and you got a 3 here,
you got to take the
Min, and it's 1.
Right, I guess that's the
number of choice today, one.
But once you do that and
you find that, you say, OK,
what I'm going to
do is-- and this
is going to be pretty
straightforward--
I'm going to look
at these edges,
and I know that I have
c of t being a one
corresponding to this value.
And I'm going to go add one
to those corresponding edges
because these are the edges
that actually shows in terms
of the augmenting path.
So the augmenting path is that.
And so this turns into s to
a to t, and that becomes 2:2.
This becomes 2:4 and that's it.
So I now have G with the new f.
So I can now think about what
is G of f1 correspond to.
The G is separate from
f, so in some sense
the G stayed the same, but the
f changed, as you saw here.
And now G f1 looks like s, a, t.
What do I do between s and a?
Well, I only have
something from a to s.
I don't have
anything from s to a
because the residual capacity
in this direction, thanks
to the fact that the flow has
saturated the edge capacity,
is actually zero.
But I do have an edge this way.
And what is the
value for that edge?
It's 2.
And over here, what
are the numbers
for the top and the bottom?
2 and 2.
And now I look at
G f1, and I've gone
through one iteration
of this pseudo code,
and I now try to find an
augmenting path in G f1.
And is there a path from s to t?
No, which means I'm done.
This is the max flow.
You believe me?
For this example,
you believe me.
You believe me, like,
for every example?
No, absolutely not because
you haven't done a proof!
We haven't done a proof!
That's why you
shouldn't believe me.
So we got to do a proof.
So how is it that we
know, given all of this,
it's not because I told you
so, that when we've converged.
When we get out of this while
loop, that we have a max flow.
Looks pretty good.
Worked for that
example and it's going
to work for every example,
but that's not a proof.
So now we have to sort of
take in all of the notions
that we've talked about here,
including primarily the notion
of cuts.
And the proof, the max
flow, min-cut theorem,
which is going to show this
key result that we require,
which is that when we
terminate in the Ford-Fulkerson
algorithm, we're going
to have a max flow.
And that's the reason why
it's a maximum flow algorithm.
If you don't have
that proof, you
don't have a max flow algorithm.
So hopefully all
of that is clear.
Pipe up if you have questions.
And let's write out the
max flow min-cut theorem,
which I mentioned
of it last time
but never really
got to even stating,
but today we're going to
state it and prove it.
So this is an
interesting theorem.
I mean it's a legendary theorem.
And it's not your usual
theorem in the sense
that it makes a
simple statement.
It actually makes
three statements.
It says the following
are equivalent,
and it's got three things
which are the following.
F equals c S T
for some cut, S,T.
This says that some
cut is saturated.
Right, so that's
just the statement.
The second statement, which is
equivalent to the first one,
says that f is a maximum flow.
So f being a maximum
flow means there's
some cut that's saturated.
If there's some cut that's
saturated for a given flow,
you have a max flow.
And then the last one,
which is important
for our Ford-Fulkerson
algorithm,
is that f admits no
augmenting paths.
And so if I want to show that
the Ford-Fulkerson algorithm
terminates with a
max flow, tell me,
based on implications--
like i implies j,
for numbers i and j, what
it is that I need to prove.
We're going to prove a bunch
of other things along the way
but crucially what is the
i implies j that I want
if I want to claim that the
Ford-Fulkerson algorithm
terminates with the max flow.
Yeah, you over there.
AUDIENCE: 3 implies 2.
PROFESSOR: 3 implies 2.
That's right, 3 implies
2, exactly right.
3 implies 2.
So we need to do 3 implies 2.
Now of course, the theorem
says that, 1 implies 2,
2 implies 3, 3
implies 1, et cetera.
There's a lot of
implications here.
What we are going to do is we're
going to show that 1 implies 2,
2 implies 3, and 3 implies 1.
And that pretty much
takes care of everything.
And it turns out
the reason we do
this is simply because it
makes for the simplest proofs.
1 implies 2 and 2 implies 3 are
one- liners, and that 3 implies
1 is a little more
interesting and involved,
but it's a little bit
easier than directly
doing 3 implies 2.
So that's the way
we're going to do this.
You could certainly play
around and do other things.
So any questions so far?
OK, so let's go
ahead and do this.
All right, we should be
able to knock these two,
1 implies 2 and 2 implies 3,
in just about a minute each.
So I want to show 1
implies 2, and essentially
what I want to say
here is, if I've
saturated a particular
cuts capacity then
I have a max flow.
And really, I mean this
comes from the definitions,
since I'm going to have f less
than or equal to the c S, T,
and this is simply because
of edge capacity constraints.
This is just edge capacities
for any cut S T, the assumption
that f equals c of S T implies
f is a maximum flow because f
can be increased.
And that's basically it.
Right, so this is pretty easy.
Next one is easy as well.
2 implies 3.
If the rare and
augmenting path--
so I'm going to do
this by contradiction--
if the rare and augmenting
path, the flow value
can be increased.
Because remember
the augmenting path
corresponds to a path
with strictly positive
residual capacities.
The only reason there's
an edge in there
is because you have a greater
than zero residual capacity.
So that means that
the flow value
could be increased by some
small amount corresponding
to C f u v, and each of
these quantities that
are in here-- I'm sorry,
corresponding to min C f u
v, that's the residual capacity.
But you know that each of
these capacities, C F u v,
are strictly greater than zero.
So the min clearly is
strictly greater than zero.
It might be some tiny quantity
but it's greater than zero.
Which means that
the flow value could
be increased contradicting
the maximality of f.
So a little proof
by contradiction
gives you 2 implies 3.
So, so far, so good.
This is primarily based
on the definitions
of augmenting paths, residual
capacities, et cetera.
Now the fun starts.
Now we want to
show really, I mean
this is truly what the max flow
min cut is because I really
didn't have cuts up there.
So what's min-cut
about that, right?
So I had a question at the
end of Tuesday's lecture
on how come the algorithm
didn't use cuts.
And, well, the algorithm
doesn't use cuts,
but showing that the algorithm
converges to the max flow
uses the notion of cuts.
So what we want to
do is do 3 implies 1,
and that's going to take
care of what we want.
And we're going to
say, well, suppose
f admits no augmenting paths.
So what does that mean?
Well, that means that
you can't reach t from s.
If you reach t from s,
there's an augmenting path,
so you can't make that
move or make that path.
So let's go ahead and, sort
of, look at this a little more
carefully and figure
out what's causing
this lack of connectivity.
There's a lack of
connectivity between s and t.
You can't actually get there.
So there's like a
chasm, there's a gap.
And so what's causing that?
And what we're going
to do is figure
out what the cut
of the partition
is that could be
the reason why you
have this lack of connectivity.
So we're going to define
S which is exactly
going to be our S from our
favorite s t cut definition,
but bear with me
for just a second.
Because I will
tell you what S is.
There exists a path
in G f from s to u.
So what I'm doing
is I'm collecting
the reachable vertices from
S. And I know that I'm not
going to have t,
small t, in this set
because f admits no augmenting
paths so I can't possibly
reach t from s.
But I can collect
all of the vertices
that that can be reached
from s in this given G of f
and put them all into S.
And then my T
definition is simply
V minus S. And the key
observation which I already
have made but
important to emphasize
is that small t belongs to T,
and obviously s belongs to S,
therefore S T is a cut.
It satisfies the
definition of a cut.
So we've set ourselves up.
And then we have
a key observation
to make that I'm going to
try and extract out or you.
Let me move over here.
All right, so what I want to
do is I want to draw this out,
and I want to look
at this as this
is S, that is T. I know
that S is over here,
are s is over here,
t is over here.
I'm going to pick some
vertex v that's over here,
some vertex u that's over here.
I know that there's
a path, and I'm
writing this is a
dotted path because this
is a path in G of f.
We're going to actually
move between a G of f and G
in this proof.
So that's the only hard
part of this proof.
The movement between
g and G of f.
The edges are different
between g and G of f.
Got to keep that in your head.
Because we're going to
make arguments about that.
I know that all of the vertices
that are on the left hand side
are reachable from s, so I just
picked an arbitrary vertex u,
and I know that
there's a path in G
of f because that's the way
I defined it from s to u.
I also know that there is
no path in G of f from u
to v because if there was a path
v would have been on this side,
correct?
So there's clearly no
path in g of f from u
to v. That's why v is over here.
But let's say that
I'm picking something
where there's an edge in G, the
original flow network from u
to v. So the edge that I've
drawn here, the dark edge,
is an edge between u and
v in G. And that edge
had a certain capacity.
It existed.
The reason it existed
is because it had
a nonzero capacity, correct?
Because we originally
defined our flow network
to be something where--
if you only put edges
in there, in the
original flow network
if the capacities were
greater than zero.
So that edge in there, in
G had some capacity c u
v which was greater than zero.
But this edge does not
exist in G of f, correct?
So what can I say?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
In the original graph, we have
saturated this edge-- that
was my best throw of the term.
I like that.
And you guys didn't notice,
but maybe it'll be on video.
Actually, it won't be
on video unfortunately.
But so I got this edge
here in the original graph
and I didn't get
this dotted edge here
because the residual
capacity was zero.
The original
capacity was nonzero.
The residual capacity is zero.
The only reason that happens is
because C f u v is zero since
if C f u v greater than zero
then v would belong to S,
not v belonging to T as assumed.
So that's essentially what
we've determined here.
So this means that f
of u v equals c of u v
simply because c f u v equals
c u v minus f u v which is 0.
All right, so that's the
statement I can make.
Now, I did not have
any constraint on u
and v. I just said u belongs
to s and v belongs to t.
And for each of
those things, I know
that I can't have edges in
the residual network between u
and v which means that any edge
that exists-- maybe there's
no edge in the original
network, but if there
was an edge in that original
network it's saturated
according to this argument.
So every edge from S to T in the
original network is saturated,
and that essentially
means that I've gotten
to the capacity of my cut.
That's essentially
what that means.
If I've saturated every edge,
I've reached that capacity.
OK, so that's it.
All you do once you recognize
that you had an arbitrary
choice of u and v, you just say
summing over all u belonging
to s and v belong to t yields
f of S T equals c of S T.
All right, I'm on a roll
not just with Frisbees.
I finished the proof
with a finger to spare.
So f of S T equals
c of S T. All right,
so that's exactly what we want.
We are saying f of S T is
obviously a cardinality of f
so I've shown this
thing over here.
So that's why the
Ford-Fulkerson algorithm works.
It's because of
this analysis that
the Ford-Fulkerson
algorithm works.
So are we done?
What are we missing in algorithm
design, our algorithm analysis?
Not you, yet.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: A runtime?
PROFESSOR: Runtime,
good runtime.
I know you have
too many Frisbees.
You probably do, too.
But so we haven't done--
we've done correctness,
we've done conversions.
We haven't done a
complexity analysis.
And so there's
some bad news here.
And erasing a pivotal
moment in 6 over 6.
Why is this a pivotal
moment in 6 over 6?
It's on the Frisbee, exactly.
This picture-- maybe not
exactly that picture.
It's not quite that picture
but it's the same graph.
It's a pivotal moment because
this picture was famous
because it was in
a textbook but now
it's iconic because
it's on a Frisbee.
We immortalized this picture.
So this is an example
of really a failure
of the Ford-Fulkerson algorithm.
So it's kind of a bad
example on this Frisbee
but it's going to lead
us to better algorithms.
So what I have here is a
weird flow network that
has these strange capacities.
I mean it's a fairly
straightforward flow network.
But at the as of the moment
it obviously satisfies
a flow conservation
because all of the flows
are 0 and therefore
edge capacities.
But we're going to now take
a pathological execution
of the Ford-Fulkerson algorithm.
Which, by the way,
did not specify
how you are going to
select the augmenting path.
It just said, find
an augmenting path.
And in passing, I said,
overuse depth-first search,
we'll use breadth-first search,
and kind of hand wave my way
through that.
Now it turns out you
can't hand wave when you
want to run algorithms, right.
You eventually have to code them
up, you got to pick something.
So people did.
People picked different
ways of selecting
augmenting paths in the
Ford-Fulkerson framework.
And they discovered that some
of them would work beautifully
and some of them
would fail miserably
on networks that were
as small as this,
and they'd just take forever.
And this is before complexity
analysis, kind of maybe
before asymptotic complexity
really came into vogue.
So they just had
empirical analysis
to tell them that some
techniques for discovering
augmenting paths work
better than other techniques
on an empirical basis.
So what could go wrong with
Ford-Fulkerson on this example?
What selection
strategy corresponding
to the augmenting path could
cause Ford-Fulkerson to have
a huge number of iterations?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So each time you
pick an augmenting path
you pick one that
goes to the center.
PROFESSOR: Exactly, and so let's
walk through a couple here.
So the first one, let's
just say this was a and b,
to make it easy.
So what is the first
path that we picked?
What is it--?
Go for it.
You're not off the hook yet.
AUDIENCE: You pick
s to a to b to t.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, and then when
you pick s to a to b to t,
I'm not going to
draw G of f for this,
it's pretty clear that G of f
is going to have-- I'm sorry,
you end up picking s to
a to b to t corresponding
to the G of f that
you've created.
Right, so the G of f might
have something like s
to a-- there's only going
to be an edge this way
that's going to
have 10 raised to 9.
And then this way it's going to
have 1, and that's going to b,
and over here to t it's
going to have 10 raised to 9.
It's also going to have
10 raised to 9 this way,
and it's going to have
10 raised to 9 this way.
And the reason the
gentleman was laughing
is because we ended
up picking this path.
S in G of f-- this is G of f
just to be clear-- you pick
s a b t.
And so what you end up doing
is you end up making this 1,
making this 1, and coming
over here making this 1.
Wow!
OK, you did increase the flow.
Very good, made progress.
Now what happens?
When you do this, certainly
you'll get a different G of f.
And the G of f is going
to turn into-- well,
this gets a little
more interesting here.
This is 10 raised to 9 minus 1.
This is 10 raised to 9--
no, that doesn't change.
This is still 10 raised to 9.
This is 10 raised to 9 minus 1.
And that this edge
here also changes
because basically
what ends up happening
is you end up going
this way with 1.
Did I get that right?
Yeah?
OK, good.
So now what's the bad path?
s b a t.
So s b a t would now say,
oh, what I'm going to do is,
I'm going to go ahead
and make this 1.
What do I do with that?
AUDIENCE: Make it 0.
PROFESSOR: Make it 0, exactly.
Make it 0, and then
this 1 becomes a 1.
Shall we keep going?
No.
So 2 billion iterations for
a graph with four vertices.
Now that's performance for you.
So this particular, potentially
a depth-first Ford-Fulkerson
on this example, depending
on the ordering of vertices
it's certainly quite
possible that you
would get to this particular
order in the depth-first search
on G of f.
The computers is dumb, it
does what you tell it to do,
it's doing depth-first search.
It's producing these
paths, and you end up
with 2 billion
iterations for this.
And how many iterations
do you really
need if you did it right?
Two.
So that's a billion
factor slowdown.
So this is a
pathological example,
a simple pathological
example, to just show you
what the problem is.
But you can imagine that if
you use depth-first search
you might be a factor of
five slower on average
than if you use some
of the technique.
And a factor of 5 is
nothing to be scoffed at,
especially if you're
running for minutes.
And, you know, back in the day
computers were horribly slow.
So how is this problem fixed?
Well, any number of ways.
But the first real way
that took into account
asymptotitc complexity, did
analysis, and did all of that
was due to Edmonds
and Karp, which
is a few years after
Ford-Fulkerson.
In fact, several years
after Ford-Fulkerson.
And their contribution was
not as much a new algorithm,
though it is called
Edmonds-Karp algorithm.
It's really a small
change to Ford-Fulkerson.
You might want to think
about it as the Edmonds-Karp
analysis, which was
kind of important,
and we're not going
to do that here.
But you'll see it in
section on Friday.
But the Edmonds-Karp
algorithm slash
analysis is that, if you use a
breadth-first augmenting path,
it's obviously just as easy
to discover complexity-wise
as the depth-first path.
Then you could get a
polynomial bound that did not
depend on the capacities
for the complexity
and therefore iteration
count of Ford-Fulkerson.
So that was their contribution.
And so the breadth-first path is
the shortest path in G f from s
to t if you count where
each edge has weight 1.
So in that case you would
get your two iterations.
You'd get the shortest
path of weight 2.
Whenever I say weight,
I mean just counting
the number of edges.
And these algorithms
they actually
recognized that
breadth-first implementations
of Ford-Fulkerson were
the ones that ran faster
than all the other ones.
And then they said, wait,
what's going on here?
This looks pretty good.
And so they went off and did a
fairly sophisticated analysis
that showed that
you had, and as I
said you'll see that in
section, that you only
need order VE augmentations
in the worst case.
So this is what we know
and love with respect
to algorithmic complexity.
Order VE augmentations,
in the worst case,
provided you used
breadth-first augmentation.
And so what is the overall
complexity of the algorithm,
let's call it the
Edmonds-Karp algorithm,
with this breadth-first
search it would be-- order?
VE square, you could
think about it as,
let's assume that e
is greater than V,
and so we just say
order V squared.
So that was the Edmonds
and Karp's contribution.
This mean that an amazing amount
of work over the past 30, 40
years on improving that bound.
[? Denic ?]
independently arrived
at a similar analysis in bound,
along with Emonds and Karp.
They were the first to give
polynomial bounds on max flow.
And there was an algorithm
that came out of MIT partly,
or at least MIT alums,
where you improve that.
And so until about
2011-- and there's
a lot of different
algorithms depending
on whether you're taking
into account the value
of the capacity, and you want to
think about this is as some max
value, and if you want to
include that in the complexity
then things change a bit.
If you can limit that.
But assuming that those
capacities are essentially
unbounded, then the
fastest algorithm in 2011
was King, Raul, and Tarjan.
And that runs in order VE log
of E divided by V log V V.
Obviously, we need
something for the log here.
So that's kind of,
pretty good here, right,
because this is pretty small.
If you really think about it,
if E's large for dense graphs
this is going to be
a small constant.
So that's pretty good.
So that was the
fastest until 2011.
Very recently,
Orlin, who's at MIT,
came up with an
order v e algorithm
and there are many variants here
that use fast matrix multiply.
And then just this
past September,
Aleksander Madry
joined our department,
and he has a variant algorithm
that is better in some sense,
not in the pure sense
of V and E but there's
a couple of
constraints associated
with it that are very mild.
But it's in that sense
better than order VE
and I won't get to that.
In the context of 6
over 6 we are obviously
going to stick with
Edmonds-Karp and Ford-Fulkerson
in terms of what
you're responsible for,
but this as been a rich area
of research for decades.
All right, yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
Oh, simply because the
breadth-first augmentation
takes order e.
I'm just saying it
takes order E time.
So this was the order VE
augmentations, in the worst
case, each augmentation
takes order E time,
because breadth-first search
takes order E time assuming
that E is greater than V and I
just added the E square factor.
Thanks for asking.
I'm sure a lot of other
people had the same question.
Yes, I just sort of skipped
over that a little too quickly.
That's why you get
the order VE square.
And so that's a
significant reduction
if you assume that constant
factors don't explode
going from Edmonds-Karp
to King, Raul, and Tarjan,
and certainly Orlin, So
now we got algorithms,
we've proven them correct,
we've done some analysis.
At tomorrow, in section,
you're going to see,
at the analysis that
gives you the order VE.
Which is a half hours worth
of pain, should I say.
Uh, no, a half hours
worth of excitement!
That corresponds to the order
VE, that bound that we have.
All right, so it's not
that difficult. It's
about the level of
this thing over here,
and maybe a little
bit more involved.
So, yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Breadth-first search
takes order v plus e time.
On a graph, breadth-first
search is order v plus e.
And I'm getting a
little lazy here,
and I'm paying for it, by
putting in the v e square.
But I should really
have been-- if I
wanted to be a stickler, I
would have put in v plus e,
thank you.
So where was I?
So we got an algorithm now.
You know, we've got a
bunch of algorithms.
Network flow is
this amazing hammer
that is being used in a
wide variety of things.
And it's been used for
matching, bipartite matching,
all sorts of things.
My favorite example
is something that
is related to
sports, I should say,
which is a baseball elimination.
So what is this
application about?
You see charts that correspond
to how your team is doing.
Standings, right?
Go to ESPN and click on
standings for baseball,
for example.
It doesn't-- now you
see pre season standings
but let's assume it's
August or something--
and you click on standings.
And you see a chart that
corresponds to games played,
games won, games
lost, games remaining,
and so on and so forth.
And back in the day
when they were just
winners corresponding
to each division
you had to win your division
to make the playoffs.
So you had to be the best.
Now if you ended
up being tied, you
ended up having to play
an elimination game.
But the whole purpose
of this analysis
is deciding whether
you still have a chance
to make the playoffs or not.
So the goal here is you
want an algorithm that
is going to look
at the standings
and decide if your
team is alive or not.
Is there a chance
of God is great,
whatever, everything goes your
way, angels in the outfield,
right?
Are you going to
make the playoffs?
And so you can be
very optimistic.
And you might think that
this is a straightforward,
I'm going to add up a couple
numbers and figure this out.
It turns out it's not quite
that simple though sportswriters
would love to think that.
That it's as simple as
adding up a bunch of numbers.
And obviously, there's network
flow lurking in here somewhere.
Otherwise, I wouldn't be
talking about it here.
So this is not quite historical
in terms of the standings.
I tweaked the
numbers a little bit
in order to make this example
a little more interesting.
But roughly speaking,
August 30th, 1996, this
was the standings corresponding
to the American League East.
And now this is
1996 so the teams
are a little bit different
from what you have.
So New York, unfortunately, was
leading the division even back
then.
Still had Baltimore.
Then there was Boston.
And then was Toronto.
And then this is back in
1996, and Detroit was part
of the [INAUDIBLE] back then.
This was before realignment.
So I just called these one,
two, three, four, and five.
Those are the positions.
All right, so Boston
was in third place.
And so, I'm going
to say these are
w i, which are the wins, so
far. l i, which are the losses.
And r i, which are
remaining games to play.
And This is usually
what you see.
I mean this is the simple
version of the standings
and I'm just going to give you
most of these, I should say.
And I'm not going to write
down what Detroit is, simply
because I'm going
to vary that number.
Because it gets interesting
as that number varies.
And each of these teams
had 28 games to play.
OK so that's usually what you
see when you see a snapshot.
OK now I'm going
to also add rij,
which are the games that these
teams play against each other.
And the reason is simple.
This linear correlation
between win loss column,
specifically
corresponding to games
that Boston plays with New York.
No ties in baseball,
so Boston wins,
New York loses and vice versa.
So I want those numbers
as well and these
are things that you
typically don't see
but they're going
to be important,
because they do determine
whether your team is alive
or eliminated.
So 5 The reason I
have dashes here
is because the team doesn't
play itself in the diagonal.
AUDIENCE: Is that
the number of games?
PROFESSOR: Yes that is
absolutely the number of games
that they're going to
play against each other.
All right so I've
got small number.
I mean 5 plus 7, 12.
Plus 4.
What is that?
16.
16 plus 3 is 19.
There's 28 games
left to play, there's
obviously games that are being
played against other teams
outside the division.
And so this is just rij, OK?
So that's the story here.
And I should say that when
I talk about this, what
are these corresponding to?
Well this corresponds to NY.
This column corresponds to
Baltimore this corresponds
to Boston, same order, this
corresponds to Toronto.
This column
corresponds to Detroit.
So otherwise it's
under specified.
Any questions about
the table here?
If you want to know,
the Bo Sox did not
make the playoffs that year.
So all that most sportswriters
do, most people do,
is say Team i is eliminated.
If wi plus ri is strictly
less than wj for sum j.
So you're just going to
say, OK you know what?
If I've won all my
games, I'm still
not going to make it
to this team that's
already won 75 games, right?
And so clearly I'm done.
That team has already
won more games
than I could possibly win.
So that's an easy one.
And so this is strictly
less, because we're just
talking about elimination,
total elimination.
You get your summer vacation,
or your fall vacation.
So let's just say
that you had Detroit,
and you're talking
about w 5 years.
You're talking about
this number here, is 46.
l5 is 88.
So they're having
a bad season here.
And you're going to
say 46 plus 28 equals
74, which is less than 75.
Therefore in this scenario,
Detroit is eliminated.
All makes sense?
So this is sufficient, but
I claim it's not necessary.
So you might actually
have false hope
if you are a Mirror
sportswriter, who
only knows to add
up these numbers
and compare it with others.
But if you were a
6046 student, and you
went through these wonderful
lectures on network flow,
you know much more.
And we're not quite there
yet in terms of requiring
the power of network flow.
But I ask, what if w5 were 47?
Can you make an argument which
clearly doesn't work here,
with this naive argument,
you have 75 equals 75.
So you still have hope.
But can you make an
argument that if w5 were 47,
given the whole table-- that's
the hint, the whole table,
that Detroit was
actually eliminated.
Worth the Frisbee
for sure, right?
Over there.
I saw you first.
AUDIENCE: It looks
like the only way
that Detroit can get more
wins than New York is
if they win all their games and
New York loses all their games?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: and if New York
loses all their games,
they're going to lose
7 games to Boston
And Boston will have 76 wins.
PROFESSOR: Exactly right.
So that's a great argument.
All right, could you stand up?
All right.
You catch well too.
So that's basically the
essence of the issue.
There's stuff going
on which corresponds
to teams playing each other
that can affect the outcome.
OK so let me write out what
the gentleman just said.
Still eliminated, boohoo,
because w5 plus r5
equals 75 now.
47 plus 28 is 75.
But either New York
or Baltimore-- I
mean there's many ways
you could show this.
But we'll just
take-- this is not
exactly what the gentleman said.
But this is what I had here,
so let me just write that out.
Either New York or
Baltimore will win 76 games.
Since they play
each other 5 times.
OK?
So now I'm going to do some
more sophisticated analysis
and I got what I wanted.
But let's say that w5 was 48.
So this was 76 and
it kind of worked out
for both of the examples.
The one with Boston and the 7
games, that I got as an answer.
And this one that
I just wrote down.
But what if w5 equals 48?
Is Detroit eliminated?
How many people think
Detroit is eliminated?
All right, a bunch of you.
You want to explain why?
AUDIENCE: So New York,
Baltimore, and Boston
are guaranteed to get a total
of at least 14 more wins.
Because of their
total number of wins
that they're allowed to have
without any of them getting
to 77 is only going to be 13.
So it will be 1 plus
5 so that's too many.
But they're not
actually eliminated,
because this is from the
Wild Card round anyway.
PROFESSOR: I didn't like the
last part of your answer.
Did, but the other question
is, did people understand
the first part of his answer?
That was complicated.
I mean it was the
right analysis.
Great job.
So, we want a
systematic way so we
can run an algorithm
so we need to bother
with this type of analysis.
And you're exactly right.
It turns out that I
skipped this little detail,
because it was
inconvenient, which
is that in '95, a wild
card was introduced.
So we could think about
this as elimination
from being the division winner.
So that's an aside.
Thanks for pointing out,
it's important to know
sports history.
Really important.
Almost as important as 046.
But basically it gets
more and more complicated
as you get closer and
closer to these edge cases.
And so you can do an analysis,
and I'll actually describe
roughly what your analysis was.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Alexander.
PROFESSOR: Alexander's
analysis was.
But I don't want to do that yet.
I'll do that at the
end if you have time.
I want to give you a general
purpose technique that
obviously is going to use max
flow to solve this problem.
All right?
So we're going to set this up.
And so that's actually
one of the nice things
about maximum flow.
How you can translate.
You can sort of create
these networks from tables
or what have you, and
add capacities to edges,
find max flows, and
solve these problems.
So this is a good
example of that.
So let's go ahead and do that
I am going to draw a flow
network based on this table.
It's going to have a source
and a sync that are basically
these dummy nodes that
are essentially going
to source about infinite flow.
But the capacities
of the edges are
going to come from that table.
And the edges themselves are
straightforward in the sense
that the graph is going
to look the same based
on the number of teams,
and the particular team
that you're analyzing.
So this graph is
trying to determine--
this is a flow network
to determine if team
5, Detroit, is eliminated.
This is just the flow network.
I'm going to have
a bunch of edges.
I'm going to just draw this
once and we'll be moving things
around on this.
2 to 3, 1 to 4, 2 to
4, and lastly 3 to 4.
And the reason you
don't see 5 here
is because this is an
analysis for team 5.
So the other 4
teams show up here.
They have edges going to t.
s is over here, and it's
got a bunch of edges
going to all of these nodes.
What are these pairs?
As you can imagine, these
pairs correspond to the games
that each of these teams
that are inside the circle
play against each other.
So 3 plays 4 a certain
number of times.
According to that
table it's 4 times.
So I'm going to put a 4 in here.
This is 4 as well.
4, 5, 7, 2.
OK?
And the edges in
between here are
going to have
capacities of infinity
and how are these
edges structured?
So far I've just explained
how the left-hand side works.
These edges have a
capacity of infinity.
1 2 goes to 1, 1 2 goes to 2.
1 3 goes to 1, 1 3 goes to 3.
And that's pretty much it.
So that's where these edges are.
That's how these
edges are introduced.
And all of these edges have
a capacity of infinity.
2 to 4, 3 to 4, and that.
So far, it's pretty
straightforward.
There's one last thing
that we need to do,
which is add capacities
to these edges.
This is actually crucial.
It turns out that we have
to add capacities such
that this max flow is going
to represent elimination.
So these capacities
have to be chosen.
And in particular
the equation for this
is simply w5 plus r5 minus w1.
In this case if it's 48, I'm
asking the question for 48
for w5 plus 28 minus 75.
So that's 1.
And then this thing
here would be w5.
I'll just write that out. w5
plus r5 minus w2, hopefully
you can read that, and that's
a 5 and then similarly this
is a 7, and that's 13.
And you might ask, what
does this represent?
Well it kind of
represents what you
think it represents if you
just look at that equation.
It says how much can
I push through here
before I get greater than w1.
So what is the capacity?
What's the difference here?
if I have a 1 here, that means
that I still see w5 plus r5,
I'm 1 greater than w1.
So in particular, if I
want to write this out,
the capacities are the
number of games team
i can win, and not have
more wins than team 5.
So this is a
statement about team 1
when I see that over there.
Our team 2 for the other edge.
And I'm just trying
to figure out
how much can I allow, with
respect to this other team,
to determine elimination
for the particular team
that I'm looking
at, team 5 or not.
So in particular,
let's say that team i
wins one particular game.
So it goes up to
it goes up to 76.
And if it goes up to 76,
it does not necessarily
have more wins then
team 5, because team 5
can go up to 76 as well.
That's pretty much
it, and the same thing
for team 2, team 3, and team 4.
So the intuition here
is the following.
So what we're going to do
is compute the max flow
and look for a certain
property on that network.
And that's going to tell
us if team 5 is eliminated
or not for the particular
choice of wi of 48,
because that's how I constructed
this particular example.
So the intuition is, assume
team 5 wins all remaining games.
That makes perfect sense.
This is the best case scenario.
You're trying to figure out,
in the best case scenario,
are you eliminated or not?
Is team 5 eliminated or not?
And what you want to do is
divvy up the remaining games.
And that corresponds to sending
flow through these edges.
So flow through these edges
corresponds to assigning wins
to teams 1, 2, 3, and 4.
That's the key.
Divvy up the remaining games,
so all teams have less than
or equal to w5 plus r5 wins.
So what does it mean if
all teams have less than
or equal to w5 plus r5 wins?
If you can divvied up
such that that's the case,
what does that mean for team 5?
Team five is still in the game.
Team 5 is not eliminated.
So if you can do this, then
team 5 is not eliminated
If you can't team
5 is eliminated.
Because some team is
going to get 77 wins.
And so that analysis that
Alexander carried out
wasn't a flow analysis.
But somehow, that's
got to be in here.
That type of analysis
has got to be
in here to show that some team
is going to get to 77 wins.
Because you know, well
thanks to Alexander,
that Detroit is going
to be eliminated here.
But we want to show that
in terms of the max flow
on this network.
So there is an associated
theorem that I'll write.
We've got enough time here.
We just have to find
the max flow for this.
And that should
take just a minute.
But I want to set it up so
that's pretty much the end.
Finding the max flow,
what that means.
But the theorem is,
which is essentially
a more precise restatement
of this observation,
is that team 5-- obviously
you can do this for any team--
is eliminated.
If and only if the max
flow does not saturate
all edges leaving the source.
I.e. in this case, the max
flow is strictly less than 26,
which corresponds to
the sum of those things.
5 plus 7 plus,
yadda yadda yadda.
And so what does it mean to
saturate all of the edges?
It means that all the
games have been played.
All the relevant games here that
affect team 5 have been played.
So you want to
play all the games,
because that's the
end game, if you will.
But basically what
that intuition here
is that saturation
of those edges
corresponds to playing
all remaining games.
And the argument is
not a proof if you
can't play all the
remaining games,
without exceeding the
capacity of i to t edges,
team 5 is eliminated.
So you have to saturate, because
you have to play all the games.
And when you do that saturation,
obviously your flow network
has to satisfy its laws
corresponding to the capacity
that we have in there.
And it's quite
possible that this
is going to cause a restriction
over here that corresponds
to requiring that
not all the games
we play in order for
Detroit to survive.
and that's basically the game.
So saturating the network
means playing all the games.
And if you get a max
flow, to be more concrete,
if you can get a max flow
here that's less than 26,
then you've saturated
all the edges
and this means that you
played all the games.
And you found this
team that beats you.
That beats team 5.
So what happens over here?
Let's take a look at this
and all you have to do here,
is to find the max
flow and then we
can go back to the
statement of the theorem.
So I want to find the
min cut corresponding
to this, which is going to
tell me what the max flow is.
I could go around for focus
in on this, and start with 0
and augment, and
so on and so forth.
But there's another way which
is not necessarily algorithmic,
but eyeballs.
Use your eyeballs and
find me the min cut here.
Which has the minimum capacity.
The min cut, the
minimum capacity
is going to tell me
what my max flow is.
We know that from the
max-flow min-cut theorem.
So I want to cut this network
into capital S and capital T
and find the max flow.
So any ideas?
It's a little hard.
So I see some people
waving their hands.
All right, let me just
do that since we're
running out of time.
It's kind of cool.
So I'm going to use
a different color.
We're going to go
like that, yeah.
and then veer over this way,
and then jump up like that,
and then come over like that.
And this is S. And
on this side is T.
So I got small s and capital
S, small t and cap T.
But I got this 4 in cap T.
Notice that I got 3 to 4,
2 to 4, 1 to 4 in cap T and I
got these other ones in cap S.
So all I've done here,
forget baseball elimination,
is find a min-cut.
And if you look at what the
value of this min-cut is,
the value of the
min-cut is simply
the capacities of the
edges that go from S to T.
So it's simply the S
to T edges and summing
over the capacities.
And if you take a
look, obviously S to T,
you've got 4 plus 4 plus 4.
So you've got 4 plus 4
plus 4, corresponding
to this one, this
one, and that one.
Do I need to add
this edge in here?
Over here?
Where does this edge go?
From this to over there?
That goes from T to
S. So that's good
because that has a
capacity of infinity.
That would cause trouble.
And so the other edges
are I got 1, 5, and 7.
So I need this one,
that one, and that one.
So 4 plus 4 plus 4, plus
1 plus 5 plus 7 equals 25.
And so this implies elimination,
because what I've done
is found the max flow, which
is strictly less than 26.
Which means that I have not
saturated all of the edges that
come out of s.
I have not been able
to play all the games.
And so if I'd played
all the games,
I'd be exceeding some
capacity constraint.
And if I push more
flow in there,
I'd be exceeding some capacity
constraint on this side.
And that would
imply that Detroit
is eliminated, because some
team would have 77 wins.
All right, so hopefully
you've got the gist of it.
I'll put this in the notes.
Take a long, hard look at it.
That particular values
aren't important.
The framework of
translation is important.
And you can certainly
ask questions of your TAs
on Friday.
And I'll stick around
here for questions.